I'm excited to talk to you today um but
I want to start um how did you get into
the reality TV production world how did
that happen oh so um I was um I was an
actor as a as a kid and then um started
you I was I was living in a van and
traveling doing Renaissance a sword
fighting show at Renaissance Fairs and
and my sword fighting partner and I
started making documentaries on sword
swallowers
jugglers uh full contact jousters we did
a little documentary in our show which
was a sword fighting show with kids um
and then in
1998 um we decided to start
transitioning off the road and my
business partner at the time had a a
music was was a a former music executive
so we started reaching out and seeing if
we couldn't um use some of his music
contacts to get into the television
business and we were able to use some of
his contacts some of my contacts and
before you know it we were shooting uh
documentaries we were shooting music
based projects we were shooting music
videos
epks um and then we started a small
production company in TCA Lake
California in
1999 and by
2002 uh you know we had a full-blown
company and we were producing television
so it was sort of uh through that that I
ended up making TV and um that's sort of
the short short version of it and then I
got out of Television for a couple of
years my daughter was born in 2003 and
it was really difficult for me to be on
the road so I went back into another um
business that I have a lot of background
in which is construction management and
I spent uh three years in P in back in
construction management um and I found
that those skills were very similar to
my production skills because it's just
about having a budget and a timeline and
a project to work on and you just get it
done and then uh when my daughter turned
three um I went back on the road and and
have been um sort of on the road and
making TV since amazing that's like such
a great journey and I love when a
journey starts as a theater kid because
I was also a theater kid so I yeah I I
did a little background on you and I
noticed that as well so could you tell I
figured we'd have that in common I love
it um so you you you kind of explained a
little bit but can you kind of elaborate
more on what exactly you do as a
producer because I know that's something
people get confused about they do and so
you know as a showrunner my job is um
I'm in charge of the I'm kind of the CEO
of the show you know that's my job is to
be over top of all departments but then
once I've hired the right people and
we're up and running then my focus has
to narrow down to story and really
making sure that we're getting the best
possible version of the story that we're
there to cover and so for me that that
means just being on top of uh keeping
that
10,000 uh foot view of what's going on
and making sure my story team my my
producers are asking the right questions
and that my director is getting the
right shots and that we're giving our
post production team the best possible
chance of making a really good episode
so I'm not sure if that answers it
specifically but um you know that's once
once the logistics are up and running
and my EIC or my line producer has that
in handled then we really start
transitioning into the Story Land
because that's what the show is really
about it's not about the grips or the
electrics God bless them all and you
know it's not about what we eat for
lunch it's about what we're going to
eventually put on television and you
know our goal is always to um to give
post the best shot at making the best
show and I think we did a good job this
time around nice and then I stay on
through post production as well and you
know and and manage the edit I'm
watching cuts and um you know we're
we're crafting the story so that again
what hits the TV is the best version of
what we can do I was gonna add that
because I know I know there's so many
aspects of producing so it was nice to
hear your like this is what I do because
it's faceted yeah that there are and you
know that executive producer role can be
many things right it can be the guy that
finances it it could be the guy that you
know know somebody who knows somebody
who gets it you know on executive
producer credit it can be you know an
executive who's really not involved in
the show but for us you know it's really
important that um you know that our role
as showrunner is really defined and we
we do just that we run the show awesome
so um you I I looked at your IMDb page
and I noticed you were a producer on one
of my favorite shortlived series A
Thousand Ways To
Die My Favorite my maybe my if I could
go back if someone said hey we're going
to reboot Thousand Ways would you do it
I would would there would be zero
hesitation on my part to go do that show
again I loved a th ways to die because
it was like making two B movies every
single day and that production schedule
was mad we would shoot two um two deaths
essentially every single day and we do
that four days a week um and we did that
for several years in a row um that show
was so much fun I got to set people on
fire blow things up gallons of B blood
stunt performers uh crash cars it was
just an absolute riot you know we make
that show for adolescence and that's
kind of like the vibe and we like I said
I I love thousand ways to die I'm glad
you do too because that was that was one
of the Thrills of my producing career
was making thousand ways to die and I
would go back and do it in a heartbeat I
love it because I was gonna ask you what
your favorite show to produce was um so
right Gordon's gonna kill me next level
Chef is probably number one for me right
now just because I love that show and we
were so so so close to the creation of
that show and it's such a fun show to
make and for cooking shows it is such a
I think we found a really fun way to
take a really tired format and make it
interesting and I think it's probably
the in my opinion it is the most
interesting cooking show out there um so
right now that's like number one I love
doing Kitchen Nightmares it was an
absolute beast but um it was so fun to
work with Gordon on that intimate level
you know it's not Gordon on a shiny
floor it's just and it's not Chef ramsy
it's just a guy named Gordon who knocks
on a front door walks into your
restaurant tries to help you out so um I
would say you know next level chef and
then Thousand Ways To Die number one and
two and then catchen nightmares of
course T first or
second it's the best one because that's
the one that's coming back and and it's
coming back after that is the one that's
back like almost a decade right yeah
almost a decade almost 10 years that's
crazy so what why why now great question
and that's a question we had to ask
ourselves and for Gordon the I think it
was seeing the world post
pandemic realizing how hard the
restaurant industry got hit harder than
I think any other industry um and it's
the one industry I think that has
changed the most since Co people's
dining habits have changed changed
dramatically since then um you know
social media didn't exist really 10
years ago when when this show came about
so you know people won't even most
people under 30 won't walk into a
restaurant unless they check their Yelp
reviews or their Instagram handle or see
if they're on Tik Tok you know um
delivery apps have changed the game
considerably um so and Gordon wasn't
immune to any of this Gordon's got 75
restaurants around the world and they
all took a hit so for him it was about
getting back in the game now to see if
he could throw a Lifeline to those
restaurants that made it through the
pandemic and then also to help some of
those restaurants that have started
since then to navigate this new world
order that we're in when it comes to the
restaurant Biz and also I think Gordon
realized too that a lot of those lessons
that were beat into people's heads over
the last 10 years
um have been forgotten or just you know
just pra those practices of um we had an
unofficial motto on the show which was U
customers shouldn't have to pay for
shitty food and that really is how G
what Gordon feels he he he realizes it
is a privilege to feed people for money
and it really makes him righteously
angry when he walks into a restaurant
and he sees these restaurant owners and
staff taking advantage of their
customers by giving them subpar food and
charging them to do it so I think all
those things definitely played into the
reason why the show is back and it has
enduring popularity I mean you can't ask
for I think a more popular series than
Kitchen Nightmares you can still watch
it every single day if you want on your
TV so I think that enduring popularity
of the show
certainly helps as well absolutely
especially uh it's always nice to see
Gordon Ramsey I mean we love watching
him cuss people out that's like super
fun but yeah it's nice to see the softer
side of him too like when he really
cares because he seems like a genuine
person and that it seems like he really
does care he does care he cares so much
about these restaurants and the people
in them I mean in the premere episode
did you see the premere episode did you
get to see Bas I mean uh b or Diner so I
mean within minutes of Gordon coming
into the restaurant and sitting down he
has grown men in tears because he really
does care and he really does want to
help and people see that in his face you
know there's the vision of and the
version of Gordon Ramsey that is the guy
on TV but when he literally walks into
your restaurant and you call him Gordon
not Chef Ramsey and he sits down with
you and he really cares about what's
going on in your restaurant and why it's
not working it affects people in a way
that is remarkable you know they say
don't meet your Heroes and I don't think
that's ever been the case with Gordon
Ramsay that's beautiful to know like
because you it's always and lately
especially I feel like dirty things
coming to light with people's favorites
and that exactly what you just said
don't meet your hero so it's always
refreshing to hear this person is
legitimate this person is who they say
they are it's so important right now it
is I I can agree with you more and I
think that is uh that's Gordon in a
nutshell what you see is definitely what
you get and he's also just so incredibly
gracious behind the camera too I mean
the way that he is conscious of how
Crews should be treated you know his
high standard for food uh is equally
High when it comes to television
production and that's super important
for us to to keep that level of
production as high as uh as high as
possible it's super important to us that
makes sense that makes sense so what
else can we look forward to you gave
some but what else can we look forward
to this even uh this is the uh
everything I think that America loves
about Kitchen Nightmares which are are
clueless owners uh egotistical off you
know off the handle chefs um lazy staff
terrible food disgusting kitchens and
then remarkable and lifechanging
transfer
of not only people but their business
and I think you're also going to see
Gordon tackle some really real world
problems that
are um are very much what's going on now
mental health in the restaurant industry
is so important to Gordon and it's not
something we shy away from it's not
something he shies away from in his
Restaurant Group he has a specific
mental health program for his restaurant
group so that
if you're not feeling it he's got ways
to help you and we like you know Gordon
really brought that with him in this and
you know there are there are definitely
um there's a huge mental strain on
people in this business and Gordon is
not afraid to talk about it he's not
afraid to embrace that and he's not
afraid to try to get People Help The
Help that they need and I think that's
something that um I think you're going
to see this go around that is um you
know that I think will resonate with a
lot of people yeah we love a great focus
on mental health because it's after the
pandemic is so important yeah and
especially in the restaurant industry
where it's so high pressure and you're
in such closed quarters and you're often
working with family and you're working
you know in a high press environment um
yeah it
was it's one of the things that I really
was we wanted to to put a focus on and
and you know we we definitely found
people who who needed the help help and
I and I'm hoping they got it amazing
well I'm hoping I I know just from
hearing everything you're describing I'm
probably going to be crying when I watch
it on September 25th yes September 25th
we air our very first episode which is
Bel Air Diner it is a family run uh
24-hour diner in Queens New York it has
been a staple in the neighborhood for
almost 40 years and it uh it is now run
by two brothers who just are absolutely
war with each other um and that just
comes from being kids who grew up
together and working with your older
brother and feeling like you're you know
not respected or U valued in the
restaurant and Gordon has to work hard
to get these two brothers back on the
same page and also get their
parents to step away these are
40-year-old men who are definitely ready
to run this restaurant and having mom
and dad there undermining their every
move
is uh is something that Gordon had to
deal with as well so that's one I think
um in episode 2 Basque 46 we have a chef
who calls himself The Culinary
gangster uh and I think you'll find that
to be um a very funny episode and and an
episode
where like you said you love to watch
Gordon chew people out but he doesn't I
think people love it because it's
righteous IND Nation right it's
everything that you want to say and and
Gordon gets to say it and I think that's
the one thing that people love and of
course we've got some absolutely
disgusting kitchens and some things that
should never be in a
refrigerator that are in a refrigerator
I think the meat free the meat
refrigerator in the b a diner goes down
in history as one of uh as definitely
one of the um if there's a hall of Shame
of Kitchen Nightmares it's definitely
going to be a first round ballot
inductee for sure and it's not the only
one we find so there's something I think
for everyone and we also have an
incredible variety of restaurants and I
think that's one of the reasons that we
pick the area that we picked was we knew
we could get a variety of restaurants um
that were reflective of uh of the
country as well you know I think
everyone in all corners of the country
will will identif y with not only the
types of restaurants but the people as
well and I I think it'll resonate for
sure awesome well I'm excited to watch
um David it's been so amazing being able
to talk to you from one former kid to
another yeah indeed of course uh Kitchen
Nightmares again September 25th looking
forward to September
25th we're coming thank you David thank
you as well I really appreciate
it